[Music]
a mother
grieving for her son a scene that is now
becoming more frequent
across myanmar
seventeen-year-old ka maya hey was one
of 74 people killed on sunday
the worst day of violence in the six
weeks of protests
the medical student was caught in the
crackdown by security forces on the
outskirts of yangon
we medical doctors initiated the civil
disobedience movement
from an early time now a life has been
sacrificed
so i'm sure we as the medical community
will not step back from the fight
we will fight until the end
while security forces continued their
crackdown the junta also imposed martial
law in six
nearby townships of yangon prompting
thousands to flee the industrial zone of
haita the location of chinese factories
that were torched on sunday
home to many migrant workers from across
myanmar it's still
unclear who started the fires
our jobs are not okay and we are also
not safe now
my parents are worried that's why we
decided to leave today
the situation is really bad i don't know
how it's going to be
it's not just the violence that concerns
human rights groups it's also that the
military will have complete control of
the six
townships now under martial law
including the courts
if you're arrested you're going to be
slammed into a kangaroo court run by the
military
for which there's no appeal of any
guilty verdict and there's a possible
death sentence or other draconian
punishments like
punishment through labor for an
undetermined amount of time
you know this is a court system run by
one of the most abusive
militaries in the world as
kahmiya hai's loved ones say their final
goodbyes there's growing concern that
the junta might expand the zones of
martial law
in its effort to stifle protests scott
heidler
al jazeera